[Musique]
alors là je suis coincé sur les toits on
a refermé la fenêtre par laquelle je
suis passé pour monter du coup je
cherche un autre accès et je vois
peut-être une issue mais comme il a plu
tout est mouillé et le petit saut devant
moi peut être bien casse gueule car je
sais pas si la tôle où je vais te voir
atterrir et mouillé ou non
j'étais en train de faire des petites
vidéos parce que je suis titulaire et il
se trouve que mon accès s'est fait tant
d'années derrière moi donc du coup je
voulais savoir si je pouvais passer par
chez vous
juste là juste par là
coutts a non seulement
merci beaucoup
[Musique]
voilà je me suis trouvé une scène
ouverte pour pouvoir accueillir avec
bonjour
[Musique]
[Rires]
commis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
petite vidéo pour nos amis étudiants
pour qu'ils cartonnent en 2022 avec
quatre petits conseils je vais me baser
sur les conneries que j'ai pu faire
quand j'étais étudiant de par exemple le
café ça on évite de prendre du café
c'est un excitant et c'est pas très bon
pour le cerveau on évite de manger en
quatrième vitesse n'importe quoi parce
que si vous ne nourrissait pas votre
corps vous ne nourrissez pas non plus
vos neurones et vous ne pouvez pas à
prendre on évite de grignoter sur son
temps de sommeil parce que je vous
rappelle que c'est pendant qu'on dort
que le cerveau va enregistrer tout ce
que vous avez fait dans la journée et
qui va être en forme le lendemain et
puis enfin bouger vous je sais qu'à
chaque fois qu'on va faire de l'activité
physique surtout si on a un concours à
préparer on se dit oh là là les autres y
bosse pendant que moi je vais courir
mais en même temps ça va vous faire du
bien ça va nourrir votre cerveau vous
allez avoir une bonne estime de vous
vous allez vous dépensez c'est donc
indispensable et avec ça vous allez
passer une super année vous allez
réussir tous vos examens